31 décembre 1986 Anne-Marie faite le
réveillon en famille
mais à 23h quelqu'un frappe à la porte
c'est Antoine sionini on vient chez les
parents le soir du réveillon
là encore au prétexte de lui parler et
elle refuse de venir à la porte c'est le
père d'Anne-Marie allée qui ouvre il a
mon grand-père pour lui dire arrête
maintenant de
noirceler quoi de l'emmerder en gros
si on Nini devient fou de rage à la
surprise générale il dégaine un pistolet
et tire à bout portant sur son beau-père
et là il lui a tiré beaucoup de médecine
de loin il faut dessus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Marseille 13 février 1996 il est 8h
quand le téléphone de la police
judiciaire retentit
on apprend aux policiers qu'un meurtre
spectaculaire vient juste d'être commis
dans les quartiers nord de la cité
phocéenne
une personne qui circulait en dans un
véhicule est abordé a été
exécuté s'agirait d'un
homme à moto qui est venu qui a fait feu
qui reparti on est à Marseille à
Marseille les policiers ont l'habitude
de ce type de situation et généralement
ça évoque immédiatement
l'hypothèse d'un règlement de compte du
milieu un règlement de compte surprenant
car la victime n'a pas du tout le profil
habituel
très vite on me dit ah c'est une femme
ah bon alors là une femme battue comme
ça on m'a dit tiens c'est bizarre quand
même une femme abattue c'est quelque
chose d'exceptionnel qu'une femme soit
abattu dans ses circonstances-là de
cette manière là c'est Thomas oui
effectivement
le mode opératoire du règlement de
compte est plutôt réservé aux voyous
enfin aux personnes
et aux hommes effectivement
[Musique]
sur place les policiers font les
premières constatations
la victime restait positionnée en place
conducteur elle a été atteinte
mortellement par plusieurs projectiles
de gros calibre la mort a été
instantanée
la femme âgée d'une cinquantaine
d'années a été touchée en pleine terre
rapidement plusieurs témoins se
manifestent ils décrivent vos policiers
une véritable exécution une exécution
qui a eu lieu en plein jour
[Musique]
un homme est arrivé
à poser sa moto
et descendu et venu assez tranquillement
vers la Renault 5 de cette dame
un homme
casse-pied sort une arme de blouson moto
[Applaudissements]
5 ou 6 projectiles et ensuite il repart
il va partir tranquillement sans courir
il va rejoindre la moto
[Musique]
manifestement le tireur est un
professionnel en tout cas son
comportement calme et posé le laisse
penser
le mode opératoire tiré quand la victime
s'arrête au feu rouge il faut faire
preuve d'un sacré sang-froid c'est un
contrat on a vraiment la signature d'un
contrat un type qui arrive en moto il
est calme il sort son arme il tire il
s'en va
sur place pas de douille pas d'empreinte
aucune trace des pneus de la moto le
tueur a été particulièrement vigilant
pour qu'on ne puisse pas remonter à lui
[Musique]
tout repose désormais sur
l'identification de la victime mais qui
est cette femme y a-t-il un élément dans
sa vie qui pourrait expliquer une fin
aussi tragique
est-ce que le vivait avec quelqu'un
un voyou qui éventuellement était
toujours impliqué dans dans le monde
dans le milieu du vanitisme est-ce
qu'elle magouiller
dans la voiture les policiers découvrent
rapidement le sac à main de la victime à
l'intérieur ses papiers d'identité et
une carte professionnelle
Anne-Marie l'enseignante qui se rendait
à son travail les professeurs de
sciences économiques et sociales au
lycée Saint-Exupéry connu par les
Marseillais comme dans le lycée Nord
elle elle sera au lycée ce jour-là ce
mardi là parce que elle va surveiller un
bac blanc Anne-Marie Alex une
enseignante de 47 ans divorcée et mère
d'un fils de 19 ans
un profil bien loin du grand banditisme
évoqué au départ par les policiers
à la aucun lien avec le milieu donc
effectivement ça tient pas trop la route
cette histoire de règlement de compte de
milieux elle est enseignante par chaque
matin travailler elle rentre le soir
elle a sa vie avec son compagnon sa
maison les copies à corriger
[Musique]
pas apparemment elle a pas une vie
sexuelle qui a tiré l'attention des
voisins c'est c'est vraiment madame tout
le monde d'un côté on a ce crime
complètement
absurde dans dans sa brutalité
qui fait penser vraiment à une affaire
du grand banditisme et la victime et
madame tout le monde donc ça colle pas
ça s'emboîte pas cette histoire
dès les premières heures de l'enquête
les policiers sont perplexes qui
auraient pu en vouloir à tel point à
Anne-Marie Alex cette paisible
enseignante marseillaise
la victime se rendait à son lycée
lorsqu'elle a été abattue les policiers
s'y rendent tout naturellement d'autant
que l'établissement est situé dans les
quartiers nord une zone particulièrement
sensible et violente à Marseille
on est à proximité de l'établissement un
petit peu comme si le tueur avait repéré
son son parcours et la guette au dernier
feu rouge elle est au dernier feu rouge
avant d'arriver au lycée
donc on peut se dire que ça vient du
lycée alors c'est de se disputer avec un
autre grand de ses collègues est-ce
qu'elle a pris la place d'un collègue
est-ce qu'elle a mis une gifle à un
élève est-ce qu'elle
a rembourou un parent d'élève les
enquêteurs entendent proviseur
enseignants et élèves mais là encore
Anne-Marie Alex semble on ne peut plus
normal
elle est décrite comme une femme
dynamique plutôt
proche de ses élèves qui s'investit
beaucoup dans dans son métier elle est
très appréciée les élèves
certains vont être très touchés même
pleurer pour certains
au fil des auditions les policiers
sentent qu'ils font fausse route
même si c'est une zone
sensible c'est il n'y a pas de problème
particulier et il n'y a pas eu notamment
avec Madame Aleix de conflits qui soient
remonté au niveau de l'administration
pourquoi un enseignant enfin collègue a
pu être victime
de telles agissements quoi exécuter
froid demain comme ça ça paraît
aberrant
Anne-Marie Alex n'avait donc aucune
raison d'être prise pour cible par un
tueur alors les policiers envisagent une
toute nouvelle hypothèse et si tout cela
n'était qu'un tragique malentendu
[Musique]
peut-être que les auteurs visaient en
leur avaient désigné une personne
circulant dans un véhicule comme ça et
ils ont fait la confusion de véhicules
et pourquoi pas c'est possible et si le
tireur croyait
penser tirer sur quelqu'un d'autre non
aux cheveux longs à la fin de leur
première journée d'enquête et malgré
toutes leurs investigations les hommes
de l'API n'ont pas la moindre piste
[Musique]
14 février 1996 le lendemain du meurtre
de l'enseignant un homme se présente au
commissariat de police
[Musique]
il a assisté à l'exécution d'Anne-Marie
Alex et il dit détenir une information
importante
un des témoins à remarquer l'auteur qui
montait sur la moto et qui qui partait
et donc il la suivi il a décidé de le
suivre pendant un petit moment
il l'a perdu de vue assez rapidement
mais il a pu relever le numéro
d'immatriculation de la moto évidemment
ça peut aboutir à quelque chose comme ça
peut aboutir à rien mais il faut
évidemment vérifier si c'est une moto
volée est maquillée effectivement là on
va dans un cul-de-sac au même moment une
patrouille de police fait une découverte
de taille non loin de la scène de crime
d'autres policiers vont découvrir une
moto
[Musique]
qui correspond point pour point à la
moto qu'il recherche on est à moins d'un
kilomètre de la scène de crime la moto
est abandonnée avec un casque et une
paire de gants les enquêteurs en sont
persuadés ils détiennent certainement la
moto utilisée par le tueur et
l'information va être rapidement
confirmée par le numéro
d'immatriculation
c'est le bon numéro c'est à dire que le
numéro relevait par le témoin courageux
qui a pris enfilature le tueur
et le même que le numéro qui figure sur
la Plaque de cette moto donc on sait que
c'est cette moto qui était sur la scène
de crime
pour les policiers et pas de doute si le
tueur a abandonné sa moto à cet endroit
c'est parce qu'ensuite il a pris la
fuite à bord d'un autre véhicule
sa confirme l'organisation entre
guillemets du
hauteur à la grande surprise des
enquêteurs la moto n'a pas été déclarée
volée son propriétaire serait-il le
meurtrier une seule manière de le savoir
de chez lui et il est ramené à l'hôtel
de police seulement quelque chose ne
colle pas
un homme pas plus connu des services de
police que saignante et le gâteau venu
il nous explique que il est bien une
propriétaire de cette moto mais il l'a
laissé en dépôt-vente depuis déjà
quelques temps
les enquêteurs se rendent immédiatement
au magasin de deux roues qui a remis en
vente la moto
nous informe que effectivement cette
moto il lui-même ne l'a plus il l'a
revendu à quelqu'un il a eu un acheteur
pour cette moto et la transaction s'est
faite le au cours du mois de janvier le
garage fait des recherches et des
retrouves effectivement le nom de la
personne qui a acheté l'engin l'acheteur
de la moto est un certain sionini
Antoine qui est domicilié dans le dans
le Var
Antoine cyonini 50 ans il est chauffeur
de taxi
et en approfondissant leurs recherches
les policiers ne vont pas tarder à faire
une incroyable découverte
[Musique]
en réalité l'homme connaissait très bien
la victime et pour cause
il se trouve que sur Nini Antoine et
l'identité de l'ex-mari de Madame Alex
pour les policiers la piste du crime
passionnel s'ouvre alors mais quelque
chose les surprend en réalité le couple
n'a été marié que deux ans et le divorce
remonte à bien longtemps
le divorcement de la 87 on est en 96
donc on se dit c'est ça fait quand même
un peu ancien pour qui est répercussions
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce jour Antoine sionini
lex-marie qui tue refroidi après son
divorce les policiers ont du mal à
l'imaginer d'autant plus que la vie de
l'homme paraît aujourd'hui bien lisse il
était pas connu
chez nous quoi puisque ça prend mal il a
été chauffeur taxi il a fait plusieurs
métiers
et c'est pas un voyou entre guillemets à
l'époque c'est c'est quelqu'un qui a une
vie totalement réglée
plutôt ce qui les convenu d'appeler une
bonne présentation on nous décrit
effectivement Antoine sur Nini comme un
chauffeur de taxi un vulgaire chauffeur
de taxi on n'arrive pas à imaginer qu'il
puisse être l'auteur ou l'instigateur
de ce crime
si Antoine sunini est le tireur quel est
son mobile et pourquoi laisser sa moto
en évidence derrière lui
pour répondre à ces questions les
policiers doivent mettre la main sur
celui qui fait désormais figure de
suspect numéro 1
les policiers n'ont aucun mal à le
retrouver puisqu'il est effectivement
il a tous cessé de ses papiers il a il a
le téléphone il a tout l'homme habite
dans le Var les policiers s'y rendent
sans perdre une minute
on a sa dernière adresse à Fréjus
[Musique]
où on va on va aller on arrive à
l'appartement et vidéo feuilleté on fait
une petite enquête de voisinage les gens
qui me disent que le Toine Soulignac a
quitté les lieux déjà depuis quelques
quelques temps la fin de l'année
95 il n'est plus il n'est plus là
les enquêteurs entendent la gardienne de
l'immeuble elle leur dit qu'avant de
partir Antoine sionini lui a laissé ses
coordonnées et le nom de sa prétendue
nouvelle rue va leur faire froid dans le
dos
il a indiqué une
nouvelle adresse rue tualleix rue
tualleix un jeu de mots macabre avec le
nom de son ex-femme les policiers
réalisent qu'ils sont face à un
meurtrier particulièrement sûr de lui
qui n'hésite pas à jouer au chat et à la
souris avec eux c'est pas un pied donné
une nargue à la police et la justice
c'est déjà c'est déjà une
une coloration de l'état d'esprit de cet
individu ce sont des aveux cyliques
provocateurs donc en l'état les
policiers ont le nom du tueur ou de son
commanditaire
et les aveux sous forme d'un jeu de mots
Antoine sionini serait donc bien le
meurtrier il revendique même son acte
problème retrouvez l'homme va s'avérer
très compliqué
à Marseille les policiers mettent tout
en oeuvre pour retrouver la trace du
chauffeur de taxi en auditionnant ses
proches ils obtiennent une information
très intéressante
en apprenant de relation de copain de
chauffeurs de taxi ils apprennent qu'il
a l'habitude de dormir enfin il lui
arrive de dormir dans certains petits
hôtels des quartiers Est de Marseille
mais il y a rien de il y a rien
d'officiel c'est des hôtels où on laisse
pas toujours ses papiers d'identité où
on ne remplit pas toujours des fiches à
ce moment-là toutes les chaînes d'hôtel
sont contactés que ce soit dans la
région marseillaise et dans le dans le
Var on a des photos de de d'Antoine
sionini donc on fait le tour des hôtels
avec la photo un véritable travail de
fourmis commence alors pour les
enquêteurs
et ce travail va finir par payer l'homme
aurait été repéré dans un hôtel du 11e
arrondissement de Marseille
lorsqu'ils arrivent dans dans cet hôtel
dans lequel les policiers entrent comme
ils sont entrés dans des dizaines
d'hôtels auparavant ils disent vous
connaissez ce monsieur il a dormi chez
vous à le gars est formel tout de suite
et oui oui il a il doit dormir il est
parti hier avant-hier le nom lui dit
rien
et en réalité là les policiers
comprennent qu'il est descendu dans cet
hôtel
à une date très intéressante puisque
c'est la veille du crime donc on est à
Marseille on fixe Antoine sionini sous
un faux nom dans un hôtel à Marseille la
veille du crime d'après le responsable
de l'hôtel Antoine sionini aurait quitté
l'établissement à moto le 12 février
c'est à dire la veille du meurtre
c'est un jeu de piste parce que il
laisse derrière lui la moto la maison
il laisse beaucoup de de c'est un peu
comme le Petit Poucet quoi et les
policiers de suivre à la suivre à la
trace mais il ne parviennent pas à
l'arrêter
le 17 février 1996 4 jours après
lassassinat d'Anne-Marie Alex les
enquêteurs entendent l'un des oncles
d'Antoine sionini
il raconte aux policiers qu'il a eu des
nouvelles de son neveu c'était justement
le jour même du meurtre et ses propos
semblaient incohérents
quelques heures après même peut-être
quelques minutes après a reçu un appel
d'Antoine sonini qui lui a dit ça y est
c'est fait sans dire plus l'oncle a rien
compris
mais nous retransmet que lui a dit
Antoine
donc nous on en déduit qui revendique en
quelque sorte le
meurtre pour les policiers c'est un
nouvel aveu mais pourquoi Antoine cenini
aurait-il tué sa femme
pour le savoir les enquêteurs se
plongent dans l'histoire de l'ancien
couple que formé Anne-Marie et Antoine
un couple qui s'est rencontré en 1976
Antoine cholini à l'époque est un grand
jeu d'homme avec des yeux bleus et donc
un peu le style au type qui plaisait aux
jeunes femmes j'imagine il avait ce
comportement un peu de belâtre comme on
dit chez nous à Marseille bon voilà quoi
rouler un petit peu les mécaniques quoi
voilà je suis grand je suis beau gosse
donc ma tante amoureuse il se fréquente
et assez rapidement
vivent ensemble et se marie et ont un
enfant
a priori Antoine sionini a tout pour
être heureux seulement il n'a aucun
emploi stable il vit de petits boulots
et en plus il est confronté à un
problème très personnel
le temps passa on y va perdre un peu les
cheveux et ça ça va être un énorme
problème chez lui alors que ça ne l'est
pas pour ni pour m'attendre ni pour
personne ou quoi je veux dire un homme
qui perd ses cheveux bon ben voilà c'est
pas bien grave mais lui on sentait que
c'était vraiment c'était c'était
viscéral ça c'est il était complexé il
était frustré de cette situation là
alors pour occuper ces journées Antoine
sionini entreprend de construire la
maison du couple à l'est de Marseille
mais malgré cela l'homme sombre peu à
peu dans la dépression il devient
irascible et violent je commence à
sentir ma tante pas bien
et elle commence à faire appel à nous
elle commence à dire que il a des propos
plus agressifs
qui a du mal à
maîtriser si il est très contrarié si la
journée avait été un peu dure avec lui
cacher les clés de la voiture ou
empêcher de partir
[Musique]
c'était un homme qui ne toléré
aucun écart au sens
large du terme s'il y a la baie 5
minutes de retard et supportait pas il
allait parfois surveiller sa sortie des
classes il allait parfois surveiller
l'entrée des classes au fil des
auditions les policiers découvrent le
vrai visage d'Antoine sionini
un homme d'une jalousie maladive qui
n'arrive parfois plus à se contrôler
Françoise Alex la belle-sœur
d'Anne-Marie en a été le témoin direct
voici ce qu'elle raconte au policier un
jour elle accompagnait Anne-Marie à son
domicile
elle ouvre la maison on pénètre dans le
grand hall et peut-être trois quatre
secondes après hop la porte
intermédiaire du garage et du hall
s'ouvre et il était là
et là je le vois mais vous savez rouge
congestionné et il avait un couteau
aussi à la main pour couper les rôtis et
là carrément il me dit j'avais tous vous
tuer toi tu seras la première et je vous
mettrai tous la tête dans les chiottes
tous les Alex vous allez tous y passer
et là elle décide à ce moment-là de se
séparer
sauf que pour lui la séparation c'est
pas envisageable
face à cette menace Anne-Marie Alex
quitte alors le domicile conjugal avec
son fils et ce réfugie chez ses parents
elle entame alors une procédure de
divorce ce qui a pour résultat
d'aggraver encore un peu plus la
situation
[Musique]
31 décembre 1986 Anne-Marie faite le
réveillon en famille
mais à 23 heures quelqu'un frappe à la
porte c'est Antoine sionini on vient
chez les parents le soir du réveillon
là encore au prétexte de lui parler et
elle refuse de venir à la porte c'est le
père d'Anne-Marie allée qui ouvre il a
mon grand-père pour lui dire arrête
maintenant de
noirceler quoi de l'emmerder en gros
rage à la surprise générale il dégaine
un pistolet et tire à bout portant sur
son beau-père
et là bébé dessus
l'homme s'écroule grièvement blessé
pour les enquêteurs l'information est
capitale
Sully est capable d'être
de commettre des actes de violence
extrême
puisqu'ils donc ils tirent
volontairement sur son beau-père et il
est condamné pour ça à la prison une
condamnation que va très mal vivre
Antoine sionini
du fond de sa cellule Antoine sionini
voit son monde s'effondrer sur sa femme
disparaît son gosse il leur verra plus
et puis pour payer les dommages et
intérêts et bien il est obligé de vendre
sa société de taxi sur sa plaque qui
vaut un petit peu d'argent mais surtout
qui va le priver lorsqu'il va retrouver
la liberté de pouvoir travailler
après un an et demi de détention sionini
sort donc de prison sans argent sans
femme et sans enfant
on pense qu'il va être calmé et en fait
pas du tout quand il sort de prison il
est déchaîné il est déchaîné et il va
littéralement harceler ça son ex-femme
là ça va être le plus en plus fort donc
elle va se déplacer plusieurs fois
déménager
ça va être dans la violence avec Harvey
mais ça va être dans le harcèlement quoi
voilà c'est que quand elle va être dans
un quartier à marcher sur un trottoir et
ben il sera en face d'elle et il lui
fera comme ça avec la mère de dire tôt
ou tard je te tuer il va lui mettre des
papillons sur son pare-brise des petits
mots sur lesquels il y a des menaces
quoi de mort c'est clairement écrit
dessus il y a pas de doute elle déposera
des mains courantes vous savez ce que
c'est vous avez des cours vous avez des
blessures non
donc c'est vrai que ça finit par
décourager parce que est-ce qu'on me
croit est-ce qu'on pense que je viens
ici simplement pour
pour faire pour faire du mal à mon
conjoint
après une semaine d'enquête sur la mort
d'Anne-Marie Alex les policiers de
Marseille savent désormais à quel homme
ils ont affaire violent impulsif et sans
doute capable de récidiver
on a aucun moyen aucun fil pour le pour
le remonter à lui
la crainte c'est que ils commettent un
autre un autre homicide effectivement
face à la menace les policiers
conseillent même à la famille Alex de
rester des plus prudentes
ce qui nous ont dit je pense que ça se
fait comme ça mais c'est de s'éparpiller
justement se mettre en cachette si vous
voulez pour éviter qu'il nous trouve la
famille Alex les membres l'intégralité
des membres de la famille Alex ou la
trouille ils ont peur parce que ce mec
est dangereux et puis non seulement il
est dangereux mais il est surtout
insaisissable moi je vis ici jour et
nuit voler fermer parce que j'ai pas de
rideau fenêtres je peux même pas dire de
pacifier les vitres donc je ferme tout
on vit dans la nuit noire quoi c'est
cauchemar après plusieurs semaines de
recherche policière infructueuse les
membres de la famille Alex de plus en
plus terrorisés vont bientôt s'inviter
dans l'enquête
[Musique]
13 mars 1996 une patrouille de police
vient d'être alerté par l'appel de
témoins d'une drôle de Seine les
policiers là de la bague de Marseille
vont ramasser deux types armés
portant des gilets parval dans une
voiture dans une petite rue de Marseille
l'un des hommes et le frère d'Anne-Marie
Alex le second n'est autre que son fils
celui qu'elle a eu avec Antoine sionini
il sonne tous les deux on peut dire un
planque devant
l'appartement d'une ancienne relation de
sionini cette histoire commence à
tourner à la vendetta si maintenant le
propre fils d'Antoine sionini planque en
armes pour tenter d'abattre son père
il y a de quoi s'inquiéter les deux
hommes ne sont pas poursuivis mais il
reste sous étroite surveillance
on reste sur place la gendarmerie est
avisé la police municipale est avisée
et
tout en surveillant on se dit aussi que
on peut éventuellement tomber sur un
tension Nini les semaines passent et
Antoine sionini reste introuvable mais
contre toute attente le suspect va faire
parler de lui une fois de plus
12 avril 1996 deux mois après la mort
d'Anne-Marie Alex on vient de retrouver
une voiture mal garée dans les quartiers
nord de Marseille
[Musique]
dans le véhicule est abandonné là les
depuis quelques temps les
voisins nous disent ça fait déjà
ce mois d'avril au moins deux mois qu'il
est qu'il est là quoi
les policiers découvrent que c'est une
voiture de location et l'homme qui l'a
emprunté n'est pas n'importe qui
elle a été louée par Antoine sionini
donc évidemment l'APJ de Marseille file
sur le véhicule
perquisitionne le véhicule cherche
différents objets et on trouve
on peut dire à l'intérieur une espèce de
dédicace de sionini à notre à notre
intention
en fait c'est un poster qui l'a qui
était resté dans la voiture qui le
représente lui
sur le Mont Blanc
une façon poursuit une ni de dire à
toutes les polices françaises qu'il est
hors de portée
il dit en gros aux deux breboys au
million boys
l'homme fait référence à Jean-Louis
Debré et Charles million les ministres
de l'intérieur de la défense en 1996
signé
Antoine sionini bienfaiteur du corps
enseignant et puis c'est sa spécialité
le jeu de mots enseignant en plus loin
sai le sang
mise en scène et provocation Antoine
sionini reste insaisissable
ça devient à la un peu
frustrant pour nous puisque donc sans
doute qu'il nous défie ouvertement sur
quelqu'un qu'on a envie qu'on a envie
d'avoir sous la main et on a envie de
mettre la main sur ce cet individu parce
qu'on a envie de la mener à la justice
là c'est
pas un homicide
comme comme les autres et en plus il est
nargue la police et il se moque de sa
victime là c'est
les enquêteurs sont d'autant plus
frustrés que sionini et malin impossible
pour les policiers de trouver la moindre
trace du suspect
[Musique]
le 15 décembre et la clôturer son compte
à la Société Générale en partant avec
plus de 163000 francs donc avec un
certain magot il n'a pas de revenus
puisque il n'a plus de il n'a pas de
pension il ne reçoit aucune pension on a
aucun fil pour le pour essayer de
remonter sur lui Antoine sionini serait
donc parti avec 37000 euros toutes ces
économies
les enquêteurs marseillais ne se
résignent pas et ils étendent leurs
recherches ils entendent à nouveau
toutes les connaissances d'Antoine
tionini parmi elles sa deuxième épouse
Yvelines
Évelyne et sa deuxième femme il a épousé
en 1994 et le mariage a pas duré
longtemps au bout de six mois
le couple avait volé en éclat sa
deuxième femme
décrit un homme très très violent
Yvelines garde un très mauvais souvenir
de son ex-mari et confirme les propos de
la famille Alex
mais elle fait aussi une révélation
capital aux policiers l'homme serait
très gravement malade
Antoine sionini était
atteint du sida il devait suivre
un traitement
positif au VIH le fait d'apprendre la
maladie d'Antoine sionini est important
pour les enquêteurs parce qu'ils peuvent
imaginer où ils imaginent en tout cas
que il a besoin de médicaments de
traitement
c'est une maladie lourde donc on pense
qu'on pourra le retrouver par ce biais
là et en l'Institut des recherches
auprès de la Sécurité sociale bien sûr
mais
aucune trace non plus
ça fait pas soigner les policiers
émettent alors des avis de recherche
d'un sionini avec et sans perruque mais
cela ne donne rien après plusieurs mois
il ne reste plus que deux hypothèses
toutes les recherches entreprises
administrativement
financièrement font que les policiers
aboutissent au même conclusions l'homme
a cessé de vivre l'homme il y a plus de
traces de vie de lui donc tout le monde
est persuadé qu'il a qu'il a mis faire
un séjour ou alors qu'il est parti à
l'étranger mais si il est parti à
l'étranger il a vraiment bien préparé
son couple meurtre avait été tellement
bien préparé organisé planifier
tout ce qui forcément il a prévu un plan
de
secours derrière quoi une cavale
pour disparaître
certainement pour nous à l'étranger quoi
il a pu passer une frontière
dans les heures qui ont suivi le meurtre
en cavale en France ou ailleurs Antoine
sionini n'échappe pas totalement à la
justice en 1998 il est tout de même jugé
pour l'assassinat de son ex-épouse
Anne-Marie
donc il va falloir que la justice
intervienne et comme on peut pas mettre
la main sur sa personne mais il va être
condamné il va être condamné par contre
tu masse c'est qu'il va permettre de
d'inscrire au fichier de personnes
recherchées
un individu qui est condamné c'est alors
la toute nouvelle brigade de recherche
des fugitifs qui est chargé maintenant
de retrouver Antoine sionini
elle va mettre en alerte toutes les
administrations du pays impôts sécurité
sociale ou préfecture si il fait une
carte grise à son nom c'est-à-dire si
son nom sort sur un réseau informatisé
d'une administration normalement il y a
une alerte qui arrive chez les flics
d'ailleurs me disait l'avocat me disais
vous savez madame Alex un jour il
commettra une une petite erreur et c'est
là qu'on attrapera
soyez patientes il me dit parce que
souvent c'est comme ça qu'on les attrape
il y a plus qu'à attendre les policiers
n'ont plus qu'un espoir que le fugitif
commettent un jour une erreur et ils
vont devoir s'armer de patience
[Musique]
oui longues années s'écoulent sans aucun
signalement dont one sionini mais le
premier décembre 2004 en milieu
d'après-midi les ordinateurs de la
brigade de recherche des fugitifs
réagissent parmi les nombreuses alertes
mises en place l'une d'elles vient de se
déclencher une alerte de la caisse
primaire de d'Assurance Maladie de
Montpellier qui va signaler à la police
judiciaire qu'il y a une demande de
prise en charge au nom d'Antoine CENI ça
fait 8 ans quand même qu'on attend en ce
moment-là ça fait 8 ans ça jamais été
aussi chaud que ce jour-là stupéfait les
enquêteurs sont presses de vérifier
l'information le numéro de sécurité
sociale d'Antoine sionini à bel et bien
été utilisé et pas pour n'importe quoi
une demande de traitement pour les
malades atteints du sida Antoine sionini
demande de prise en charge pour pour une
traité rapide ça peut être que le bon
donc ils fonce l'homme habiterait
Montpellier dans une petite résidence
les hommes de l'APJ siront immédiatement
mais ils sont confrontés à un problème
le seul Antoine qui trouve dans
l'immeuble c'est un certain Antoine
Canovas bon Canovas sionini est-ce que
c'est le même est-ce que c'est son faux
nom on sait que dans les hôtels il est
sous des faux noms bon ça vaut le coup
de vérifier mais ils se disent quand
même on va être prudent on va mettre un
petit dispositif là on va planquer comme
on dit donc les policiers se mettent en
planque devant l'immeuble et ils vont
attendre de voir rentrer sortir les
occupants de l'immeuble mais soudain un
homme attire leur attention
[Musique]
et assez rapidement il voit un type avec
une casquette qui a l'air assez amaigri
fatiguée affaibli
et les enquêteurs avec les photos qu'ils
ont
persuadés c'est les mêmes traits ils
disent c'est lui c'est lui comme
vraiment ce qu'on avait envisagé il
n'est pas il ne sait pas suicidé il
n'est pas à l'étranger il a il est
arrivé à
refaire sa vie quoi sous
un autre nom et voilà on est en
finalement pas si loin que ça quoi le
principal suspect du meurtre
d'Anne-Marie Alex a donc été retrouvé
pour les policiers il s'agit désormais
de faire vite mais pour éviter toute
bavure il décide d'interpeller l'homme à
son domicile
quelques heures plus tard les hommes du
SRPJ Montpellier pénètre dans
l'appartement de sionini il fait pas
fort à la mort
il est il est pris
Canova s'est pris
après huit années de cavale Antoine
sionin n'oppose aucune résistance et les
policiers ne sont pas au bout de leur
surprise
[Musique]
car dans une boîte négligemment rangée
dans son salon il fonde une découverte
[Musique]
très vite il trouve un 357 Magnum il
déverrouille le barillet il regarde il y
a six douilles vide
et Antoine sionini dira c'est les
douilles des balles qui ont servi à tuer
mon accès
les enquêteurs sont abasourdi pendant 8
ans Antoine sionini a conservé l'arme du
crime et il revendique maintenant le
meurtre
il est immédiatement transféré en prison
pour les policiers et la famille de la
victime c'est un soulagement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que du coup il était bien en
France à Montpellier à si loin que ça
finalement et donc là c'est un gros
soulagement parce qu'on se dit mais ça y
est quoi c'est fini il est arrêté c'est
une joie immense pour nous c'est une
satisfaction énorme que
la justice est plus mettre la main sur
sur cette individu c'est inimaginable
c'est impensable sur si on fait un roman
à partir de de ça on va dire qu'on dit
pas la vérité quoi c'est impossible dès
le lendemain matin à Marseille Antoine
sionini passe aux aveux avec une
certaine satisfaction
il avoue immédiatement tout comment ça
s'est passé
il va décrire je dirais presque avec
délectation
la mise en scène de son crime
quant au mobile il n'a rien de
passionnel il reproche à Anne-Marie de
l'avoir ruiné tout simplement
son geste et il explique par les motifs
financiers l'argent qui lui a été pris
ce divorce qu'il a
mis sur la paille
voilà c'est le motif principal bon bah
oui oui j'ai décidé de tuer quelqu'un
j'ai décidé de tuer quelqu'un et
regarder les méchancetés qu'elle m'a
fait
en me prenant des sous qu'elle aurait
pas dû me prendre si on y ne fait preuve
d'aucun remords il a tué son ex-femme
tout seul selon un scénario
minutieusement préparé
quant à sa cavale de huit ans l'homme
trouve un malin plaisir à expliquer
comment il a pu déjouer les autorités
pendant si longtemps
il vit à Montpellier sous le nom
d'Antoine Canovas il va réussir à
travailler il va là aussi réussir à
occuper des différents emplois c'est un
caméléon qui
va noué d'abord des liens forts avec une
personnage et qui va le faire vivre chez
lui va s'occuper du jardinage ensuite il
va arriver à madouer un coup un couple
de psychiatre c'est quelqu'un qui qui
sait jouer qui sait se mettre en avant
qui sait parler de lui qui est plutôt un
beau parleur qui sait parler donc
personne pendant toutes ces années ne
s'est doutait de quoi que ce soit une
question taraud de tout de même le juge
pourquoi avoir commis cette erreur en
utilisant son vrai nom pour une demande
de trithérapie et ce après tant d'années
d'une cavale réussie
la réponse est très simple
[Musique]
l'argent commence à manquer est-ce que
ça c'est aussi quelque chose de très
connu une vie de cavale ça coûte très
cher il est plus de boulot il est plus
d'argent et il y a la maladie qui
continuait à le ronger gravement et du
coup il avait pas d'autres solutions que
pour sauver sa peau en se disant
peut-être que au bout de 8 ans les
recherches enfin les vérifications
serait peut-être
il passera peut-être à la s'il est pas
dans le même département
donc il a tenté le coup cette erreur le
conduit directement devant la Cour
d'Assise d'Aix-en-Provence le 6 mai 2006
il est condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle Antoine sionini fait
immédiatement appel et l'histoire et
loin de s'arrêter là
un an plus tard cours d'appel de
Draguignan Antoine sionini n'est plus le
même homme malade depuis plus de 10 ans
l'accusé est très diminuée physiquement
[Musique]
je me suis cholini on dirait qu'il a 20
ans de plus
je crois qu'il a dans les alentours dans
les 60 ans et puis on dirait qu'il en
fait 80
amaigri affaibli Antoine sionini a
arrêté son traitement contre le sida il
dit vouloir mourir
[Musique]
mais il aura du mal à pitoyer l'audience
car Yvelines sa seconde épouse est
appelée à la barre et elle fait le
portrait d'un homme tyrannique
décrit son couple avec lui et qu'on a
l'impression vraiment
de
réentendre
et de revivre la vie d'Anne-Marie allée
c'est-à-dire qu'on voit bien qu'il est
avec une nouvelle femme mais qu'il est
dans un même circuit de harcèlement de
manipulation de pression
morale etc
l'effet est dévastateur sionini est
condamné à une peine plus lourde qu'en
première instance 22 ans de réclusion
criminelle
tout le monde pense alors que le
feuilleton sionini a touché à sa fin
mais contrairement aux apparences
l'homme réserve de nouvelles surprises à
la justice
[Musique]
juillet 2008 Antoine sionini croupie au
fond de sa cellule
lui qui a arrêté de prendre son
traitement antiviral et très gravement
affaibli au point même d'alerte médecin
et juge d'application des peines
il fait des malaises il ne s'alimente
plus il est incapable de s'alimenter
tout seul il a perdu beaucoup de kilos
en tension Nini va mourir dans les jours
qui suivent c'est la raison pour
laquelle la chambre l'application des
peines n'hésite pas et le revint en
liberté on considère et à mon avis c'est
tout à fait normal que c'est pas une
mordine que de que de mourir en prison
et que quel que soit l'effet qui est
plus commettre quelqu'un d'une part il
vaut mieux qu'il aille mourir
éventuellement à l'hôpital ce qui
malheureusement le doute beaucoup de
gens voir dans le meilleur des cas chez
lui plutôt que dans une cellule à
l'intérieur de la prison condamné à 22
ans Antoine sionini retrouve la liberté
au bout de quatre ans
[Musique]
mais l'homme est à l'article de la mort
il trouve refuge dans un petit village
des Cévennes chez une amie lorsqu'il
arrive il ne pèse plus que 50 kg il va
retrouver une de ses anciennes amis chez
qui va s'installer pendant plusieurs
mois quatre mois je crois et là il se
refait la il se refait la santé il
remange il se réalimente il reprend son
traitement
trois ans passent constatons que son
état de santé s'est amélioré les juges
décident de contraindre sionini à purger
sa peine avant de le renvoyer en prison
ils ordonne une dernière expertise
médicale au docteur benslima
est arrivé tout à fait normalement je
dirais sans aucun problème l'examen se
passe
dans de bonnes conditions il y avait
aucune incompatibilité à ce que le
traitement soit poursuivi en milieu
castéral mais lorsqu'il l'apprend
antoine sionini va tout faire pour ne
pas retourner en prison
il tente à la fois de nous apitoyer sur
ces pathologies qui sont réelles et sur
le fait que il se présente comme un
vieil homme et on dit ben écoutez non
désolé mais ça fait maintenant quand
même pas mal de temps que vous avez
bénéficié de cette suspension de punch
médical le texte est clair c'est en
raison de l'état de santé or votre état
de santé si vous prenez votre traitement
donc nous décidons effectivement à ce
moment-là de le faire réincarrer le 2
avril 2011 Antoine sionini doit se
présenter à la prison de Nîmes pour
effectuer les 18 années qui lui restent
à purger
le problème c'est que l'homme refuse d'y
retourner évidemment il va pas
réintégrer la maison d'arrêt au moment
d'aller le chercher de force les
policiers découvrent alors que l'homme a
organisé sa fuite
on apprend que il a vendu petit à petit
tous ces meubles qui s'est constitué un
petit pécule et que
il s'est préparé à une nouvelle période
de cavale
les enquêteurs se lancent sur ces traces
ils le savent Antoine sioninier est un
homme dangereux et il va se montrer
fidèle à sa réputation
[Musique]
5 avril 2011 à Marseille maître roi un
avocat de la ville se rend à son cabinet
lorsqu’un homme se jette violemment sur
lui
agression violente à coups de points de
pieds et également de gaz lacrymogène
l'avocat reconnaît son agresseur c'est
un ancien client à lui il se trouve que
cette avocat est l'avocat du divorce
d'Antoine scianini et d'Anne-Marie Alex
vous voulez beaucoup à cet avocat pour
la perte en fait financière qu'il avait
subi
toutes les forces de l'ordre de la
région sont alors en état d'alerte
il faut à tout prix retrouver Antoine
sionini avant qu'il ne s'en prenne à
quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
le lendemain de l'agression de l'avocat
la gendarmerie de Grasse reçoit un appel
d'urgence une femme a été rouée de coups
elle est laissée pour morte à
Saint-Césaire un petit village des
Alpes-Maritimes
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il y
ait pas aller de ma morte il a assommé
un coup de marteau
en tapant toutes ses forces il lui a pas
mis une claque
la femme agressée n'est autre que
Yvelines la seconde ex-femme d'Antoine
swanini l'homme l'a frappé de 7 coups de
marteau sur le crâne et il l'a laissé
inconsciente mais vivante
il lui reproche de l'avoir trahi et
d'avoir
tenu faux témoignage à la barre de les
deux cours d'assises qui l'ont jugé
toutes les autorités sont sur les dents
Antoine sionini ce serait lancé dans une
cavale meurtrière
après son ancienne avocat son ancienne
femme qui pourrait être sa prochaine
victime
qui désespéré et qui est susceptible
d'agir contre les autres directement
menacés les membres de la famille Alex
sont alors prévenus de la nouvelle
cavale de sionini
tous redoutent sa vengeance
oui il était malade donc ça fait trois
ans qu'il est dehors
c'est pas possible personne n'était
prévenu même pas notre avocat ça fait
donc trois ans qu'il a eu la possibilité
de nous épiller de voir nos habitudes et
de remettre encore en place quelque
chose là il y a une colère qui revient
qui gronde
parce qu'à nouveau on se dit mais c'est
pas possible ça va pas recommencer quoi
s'engage alors une course contre la
montre les gendarmes veulent à tout prix
éviter un nouveau drame et ils vont
finir par retrouver la trace du
meurtrier grâce à son téléphone portable
le 25 avril 2011 une conversation
téléphonique entre cet ami et lui-même
va permettre aux gendarmes de
géolocaliser son téléphone portable dans
une commune de Tallard
qui ironie du sort est un petit village
dans lequel il a vécu avec sa victime
avec Anne-Marie Alex en deux ans donc
tout ça sent bon entre guillemets
le jour même les gendarmes procèdent
sans difficulté à l'arrestation de
sionini il est sur un parking en plein
centre du village
l'homme n'oppose aucune résistance les
conduits immédiatement en garde à vue ou
il va reconnaître sa responsabilité dans
les deux agressions qui qui lui sont
reprochés cette fois-ci la cavale
d'Antoine sionini aura duré trois
semaines l'homme est aussitôt incarcéré
à la maison d'arrêt de Grasse
pour la famille Alex
c'est la fin d'un cauchemar quand il
m'appelle il me
[Musique]
dit j'étais heureuse j'étais contente
mais toujours en arrière-plan je me
disais cette fois-ci il faut pas qu'il
le relâche il faut qu'il le garde
vraiment qu'il le mette en prison mais
qu'on en parle plus quoi ça suffit
au moment où il rentre en prison Antoine
sionini encore 17 ans a purger pour le
meurtre d'Anne-Marie Alex alors qu'il
attend un nouveau procès pour avoir
essayé d'assassiner son ex-femme
Yvelines
son état de santé semble très
préoccupant
et plus désespéré que jamais donc
il cesse aujourd'hui encore son
traitement donc il est dans un état de
santé qui est proche de de la mort en
fait il est en sursis à tout moment il
alterne et ses jours à la maison d'arrêt
de Grasse avec des séjours à l'hôpital
Nord unité de soins spécialisés de
Marseille finalement l'homme sera
condamné en janvier 2013 à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle
à moins qu'il ne sortent avant pour
raison de santé
[Musique]